Cuando decimos que preferimos a George Clooney sobre Tom Hanks
por su compromiso con el medio ambiente,
¿es realmente cierto?
Se puede ser totalmente sincero y creer genuinamente
en el motivo que explica nuestra elección,
pero yo creo que algo está faltando.
Tal como están las cosas, y dada la naturaleza de la subjetividad,
resulta muy difícil poder demostrarle a alguien que se ha equivocado.
Soy psicólogo experimental,
y en el laboratorio hemos estado tratando de resolver este problema.
Queríamos diseñar un experimento
que nos permitiera cuestionar lo que la gente dice de sí misma,
independientemente de cuán segura parezca.
Pero engañar a las personas sobre lo que piensan no es fácil,
por eso recurrimos a los profesionales:
los magos.
Son expertos en crear la ilusión de una libre elección.
Cuando dicen "Elige cualquier naipe",
lo único que sabemos es que esa elección ya no es libre.
Pues bien, luego de intercambiar ideas
con un grupo de magos suecos,
creamos un método
para poder manipular el resultado de las decisiones de la gente.
De esta manera, podríamos saber cuándo la gente se equivoca,
aun sin saberlo.
Les mostraré ahora un breve video sobre esta manipulación.
Es muy simple.
Los participantes deben elegir una opción,
pero yo les doy la opción que descartaron.
Y luego veremos cómo reaccionaron y qué dijeron.
Es sencillo, pero traten de detectar dónde está el truco.
Esto fue filmado con participantes
que no sabían cómo era la prueba.
(Video)
P. Johansson: Hola. Soy Petter. Mujer: Hola, soy Becka.
PJ: Te mostraré unas fotografías
y debes decidir cuál de estas personas te parece más atractiva.
Becka: Muy bien.
PJ: Y a veces te preguntaré también por qué la elegiste.
Becka: Perfecto.
PJ: ¿Lista? Becka: Sí.
PJ: ¿Por qué elegiste esa?
Becka: Por la sonrisa, creo.
PJ: La sonrisa.
Hombre: La de la izquierda.
De nuevo, simplemente me gusta.
Una foto interesante.
Soy fotógrafo. Me gusta la iluminación y la toma.
Petter Johansson: Pero este es el truco.
(Video) Mujer 1: Esta.
PJ: Les doy la otra foto, no la que eligieron.
Y veamos qué ocurre.
Mujer 2: Mm...
Lo veo más inocente que el hombre de la otra foto.
Hombre: La de la izquierda.
Me gusta la sonrisa, la forma de la nariz y de la cara.
La veo más interesante; me gusta el peinado.
Mujer 3: Esta.
Me gusta esa sonrisa afectada.
PJ: Te gusta más esa sonrisa.
(Risas)
Mujer 3: Este.
PJ: ¿Por qué lo elegiste?
Mujer 3: No sé, se parece un poco al Hobbit.
(Risas)
PJ: ¿Y qué ocurre cuando al final les digo cómo es el experimento de verdad?
Es todo. Ahora te haré unas preguntas.
Hombre: Seguro
PJ: ¿Qué te pareció? ¿Fácil o difícil?
Hombre: Fácil.
PJ: Durante el experimento,
cambié las fotografías tres veces.
¿Lo notaste?
Hombre: No, en absoluto.
PJ: ¿Para nada? Hombre: No.
Cambiar las fotos... ¿en qué sentido?
PJ: Claro, tú elegías una, pero yo te daba la otra.
Hombre: La otra ... No.
Bueno, esto demuestra cuán concentrado estaba.
(Risas)
PJ: ¿Notaste que durante el experimento a veces yo cambiaba las fotografías?
Mujer 2: No, no me di cuenta.
PJ: Tú elegías una, pero yo te daba la otra.
¿Ninguna sospecha de lo que ocurría?
Mujer 2: No.
No me di cuenta.
(Risas)
PJ: Gracias.
Mujer 2: Gracias a ti.
Petter Johansson: Como habrán notado,
el truco es que tengo dos fotos en cada mano
y, cuando les entrego una de ellas,
la foto negra se confunde con el color negro de la mesa.
En este tipo de experimentos,
menos del 20 % de los participantes suele detectar el truco.
Y como vieron en el video,
cuando al final se les cuenta la verdad,
se muestran muy sorprendidos
y a menudo se resisten a creer que ha habido un truco.
Esto demuestra que el efecto es bastante contundente y genuino.
Pero si a Uds. les interesa el autoconocimiento, como a mí,
la parte más interesante es cómo justificaron sus decisiones.
Analizamos las explicaciones que dan los participantes.
Este gráfico muestra
que si comparamos lo que dicen en un experimento manipulado
respecto de uno no manipulado, es decir,
cuando explican una decisión real y una donde el resultado es manipulado,
vemos que las explicaciones son increíblemente parecidas.
Son igual de emocionales, igual de específicas,
expresadas con el mismo nivel de certeza.
Entonces, la firme conclusión
es que si no hay diferencias
entre una elección real y una elección manipulada,
quizá estemos inventando cosas todo el tiempo.
Pero también hicimos estudios
donde tratamos de relacionar lo que dicen con la cara que eligen.
Y descubrimos esto.
Este participante eligió la chica de la izquierda,
pero le dimos la foto de la derecha.
Y justificó su elección diciendo:
"Es radiante.
Preferiría acercarme a ella en un bar y no a la otra chica.
Y me gustan los pendientes".
Lo que inicialmente lo llevó a elegir la chica de la izquierda
no fueron precisamente los pendientes, pues quien los tenía puestos era la otra.
Este es un claro ejemplo de una construcción 'a posteriori':
justificaron la decisión después.
Este experimento muestra
que si no logramos detectar que nuestra elección fue cambiada,
inmediatamente intentaremos explicarla de alguna manera.
Y descubrimos también que muchas veces los participantes
terminan prefiriendo la alternativa que habían elegido bajo un engaño.
O sea que, si les damos a elegir de nuevo,
eligen la imagen que antes habían rechazado.
Este efecto se llama "ceguera a la elección".
Hemos hecho una variedad de estudios
sobre la elección del consumidor,
elecciones realizadas con base en el sabor y el olor
e incluso problemas de razonamiento.
Pero lo que queremos saber
es si esta conducta también rige decisiones más complejas e importantes.
Por ejemplo, las relacionadas con cuestiones morales y políticas.
El siguiente experimento requiere cierto contexto.
En Suecia, el panorama político
está dominado por dos coaliciones: una de derecha y una de izquierda.
Y los votantes pueden fluctuar entre partidos dentro de cada coalición,
pero hay muy poco movimiento entre una coalición y la otra.
Y, antes de cada elección,
los periódicos y los institutos de sondeo
crearon lo que ellos llaman "una brújula electoral",
que consiste en una serie de temas polémicos
que dividen a ambas coaliciones.
Por ejemplo: si el impuesto a la gasolina debería incrementarse.
O si los 13 meses de licencia pagada por paternidad o maternidad
deberían dividirse equitativamente entre ambos padres
para fomentar la igualdad de género.
Pues bien, antes de las últimas elecciones en Suecia,
creamos nuestra propia brújula electoral.
Salimos a la calle y le preguntamos a la gente
si quería participar de una rápida encuesta política.
Primero les pedimos que manifestaran
su intención de voto entre las dos coaliciones.
Luego les pedimos que respondieran estas 12 preguntas.
Completaban con sus respuestas,
y luego les pedíamos que explicaran, por ejemplo:
¿Por qué considera que el impuesto a la gasolina debería incrementarse?
Y así seguimos con las otras preguntas.
Luego, usando una plantilla con códigos en colores,
calculamos el puntaje total.
Así, esta persona tendría uno, dos, tres, cuatro ...
cinco, seis, siete, ocho ... nueve puntos a la izquierda,
lo cual indica su tendencia a la izquierda, básicamente.
Y finalmente, debían expresar nuevamente su intención de voto.
Pero, claro, también aquí había un truco.
Primero nos acercábamos a las personas,
les preguntábamos su intención de voto
y, mientras completaban las respuestas,
nosotros escribíamos las respuestas que iban en dirección opuesta.
Poníamos esas repuestas debajo del bloc de notas.
Y cuando nos devolvían el cuestionario,
simplemente las pegábamos encima de las respuestas del participante.
(Risas)
Y allí está.
Y luego preguntábamos por cada una de las respuestas:
"¿Cuál fue su razonamiento en este punto?".
Exponían sus razones,
juntos calculábamos el puntaje total.
Y al final escribían nuevamente su intención de voto.
Lo primero que descubrimos
es que estas manipulaciones son detectadas muy pocas veces.
Con 'detectar' no me refiero a que digan:
"Tendrás que haber cambiado mi respuesta",
sino más bien:
"Está bien, debo haber malinterpretado la pregunta.
¿Puedo cambiarla?".
Y aunque hayamos corregido algunas de estas manipulaciones,
la gran mayoría pasó desapercibida.
Así que logramos cambiar el 90 % de las respuestas de los participantes
de izquierda a derecha, de derecha a izquierda; su perfil general.
¿Y qué sucede cuando se les pide justificar esas decisiones?
En este punto, las explicaciones son mucho más interesantes
en comparación con la prueba de las caras.
La gente dijo cosas como estas. Las leeré:
"El control gubernamental a gran escala de correos electrónicos e Internet
debería estar permitido para combatir el delito y el terrorismo internacional".
"¿Está de acuerdo en cierto modo con esta afirmación?". "Sí".
"¿Cómo justifica su postura?".
"Bueno...
es tan difícil luchar contra el delito y el terrorismo internacional
que creo que deberían existir herramientas de este tipo".
Y luego la persona recuerda un artículo publicado en el periódico matutino,
"En el periódico de hoy
dicen que pueden escuchar los móviles de la prisión
si el líder de una banda quiere seguir delinquiendo desde adentro.
Es una locura no tener el poder suficiente
parar poner freno a estas cosas
cuando en realidad existe la posibilidad de hacerlo".
Y luego se ve una vacilación sobre el final:
"No me gusta que tengan acceso a todo lo que uno hace,
pero creo que a la larga vale la pena".
Si ignoráramos que esta persona
participó de un experimento de ceguera a la elección,
no cuestionaríamos su sinceridad.
¿Y qué pasa después con la intención de voto?
Lo que descubrimos también está influenciado por el cuestionario.
Hay 10 participantes
que fluctúan de la izquierda a la derecha, y viceversa.
Hay otros 19 que fluctúan de una intención de voto segura
a otra incierta.
Otros van de la incertidumbre a la intención segura.
Y después están los que manifiestan incertidumbre en todo el cuestionario.
Y este grupo es interesante porque,
según los institutos de sondeo,
cuanto más cerca está la elección
los únicos votos que están en juego
son los de la gente que está en la franja de indecisos.
Pero nosotros demostramos que hay un número mucho mayor de personas
que consideran la posibilidad de cambiar de opinión.
Y en este punto aclaro que no está permitido usar este método
para alterar el voto de la gente
antes de una elección;
nosotros les explicamos después
y les dimos la oportunidad de retroceder y decidirse
por la elección inicial.
Esto demuestra que si podemos hacer que la gente vea la postura opuesta
y se haga sus propios cuestionamientos,
podría cambiar de opinión.
Bien.
¿Qué significa todo esto?
¿Qué les parece que está sucediendo aquí?
En primer lugar, gran parte de lo que llamamos autoconocimiento,
es en realidad interpretación subjetiva.
Hago una elección y, cuando debo justificarla,
simplemente intento explicarla
de la manera más racional posible.
Pero lo hacemos tan rápido y con tanta facilidad
que creemos saber la respuesta cuando explicamos el porqué.
Y como es una interpretación,
a veces cometemos errores,
de la misma manera en que cometemos errores
al intentar entender a otras personas.
Por eso debemos tener cuidado al preguntar "¿por qué?".
Porque lo que puede pasar si preguntamos
"¿Por qué tienes esta postura?".
"¿Por qué sigues en este trabajo o en esta relación?",
es que estemos creando una actitud
que no existía antes de hacer la pregunta.
Y esto es importante también en nuestra vida profesional,
o podría serlo.
Si diseñas algo y luego preguntas,
"¿Por qué piensa Ud. que esto es bueno o malo?".
O si eres un periodista que entrevista a un político,
"¿Por qué tomó Ud. esta decisión?".
O si eres un político
e intentas explicar por qué tomaste una determinada decisión.
Puede resultar inquietante,
pero si vemos el lado positivo,
se lo puede interpretar
como que somos más flexibles de lo que creemos,
que podemos cambiar de opinión,
que nuestras opiniones no son inamovibles.
Y también podemos cambiar la opinión de otros,
con solo hacerlos razonar para que vean la postura opuesta.
Y en mi vida personal, desde que empecé con esta investigación,
con mi pareja acordamos
que está permitido retractarse.
Si dije que algo me gustaba el año pasado
no significa que me deba seguir gustando.
Liberarse de la necesidad de mantenerse en una posición
representa un gran alivio y facilita las relaciones.
La conclusión, entonces, es:
Debes saber que no te conoces...
o al menos no tan bien como crees.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)